[Chantant] Ho ! Happy Day !
Ho ! Happy Day !
Salut, pour que ce jour reste un jour "happy"
je vais arrêter de chanter,
et je vous parle aujourd'hui du "Pi Day"
[Musique de générique]
Le "Pi Day" c'est le jour où
l'on célèbre π
Non, ne fuyez pas, rester ici je vais juste
vous dire des choses intéressantes sur π
que peut-être vous
ne savez pas encore.
Et à la fin de la vidéo,
je vous donnerai également une dernière conclusion par rapport au deux vidéos qu'il y a eu ce week-end.
Ce n'était pas non plus un drama.
Le 14 Mars c'est donc le jour de π
le "Pi Day"
Parce que autant en France,
on écrit 14 Mars : 14.03
autant outre-atlantique,
ils l'écrivent à l'envers.
Donc 03.14 : 3,14 "Pi Day"
La première journée vraiment dédiée à π
a eu lieu en 1988 à l'Exploratorium.
J'ai pas trouvé d'image exacte
de cette première fois,
mais la représentation que
j'en ai lu est marrante
puisque tout le personnel et le public
marchaient en cercle,
Pour célébrer π.
Tout en manger des tartes,
des "pies" en anglais...
Le pire c'est que ça m'aurait plu
de faire ce genre de délire.
Alors, il y a toujours des tartes
maintenant au "π-Day",
là-bas à l'Exploratorium.
Mais depuis ils ont également ajouté
des "pi-zza".
Et "pi" c'est tout !
Et le fondateur du "π-Day"
c'est Larry Shaw,
un ancien physicien,
qui est retraité
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui,
mais qui s'occupe toujours de l'événement,
chaque année.
Alors π c'est quoi ?
Ben, π on le connait parce que
c'est le nombre par lequel il faut
multiplier le diamètre d'un cercle
pour connaitre la circonférence
du même cercle.
D'ailleurs l'appellation "π"
n'a pas été choisie au hasard,
puisque π c'est la première lettre du mot grec
qui signifie "périmètre".
Et ce nombre-là, cette constante-là à toujours fasciné tout le monde, même 2000 ans avant Jésus Christ,
les mathématiciens s'intéressaient déjà à π et avaient déjà constaté que ce n'était pas un nombre rond.
Et pour le calculer à l'époque ils utilisaient un principe géométrique qui consistait à construire deux polygones
réguliers !
ayant le même nombre de côtés
à l'intérieur du cercle et à l'extérieur du cercle.
Et ils cherchaient comme ça
un encadrement de la valeur de π.
Donc en construisant des hexagones
(des polygones à 6 côtés)
comme quand on encadre la France,
on trouve que π est compris entre
3 et 3,47
Et c'est Archimède qui,
en -250 avant Jésus-Christ,
a fait ce calcul là avec
des polygones de 96 côtés.
Et il a trouvé environ 22/7
soit 3,1418.
C'est pas si mal quand même !
On est en -250 avant JC les gars !
Bon alors on l'a déjà dit sur cette chaine,
π est un nombre irrationnel.
Ça veut dire que sa suite de décimales
est non répétitive et surtout infinie.
Et depuis Archimède on continue d'essayer
de calculer le plus précisément possible π.
Et là on pourrait se dire
qu'avec l'arrivée des ordinateurs
ça a été super facile d'avoir des milliards
et des milliards de décimales...
Non!
C'est seulement en 1949 que l'ENIAC a utilisé l'ordinateur à des fins comme ça
de recherches publiques,
Et ils sont arrivés à 2037 décimales
seulement.
Je dis "seulement" pour aujourd'hui,
parce que pour l'époque c'était énorme !
C'était une précision énorme !
Est-ce que j'ai bien dit que c'était énorme ?
Et c'est seulement en 1973 que si les décimales avaient été des abonnés π aurait reçu son trophée.
Puisqu'en 73 on a passé le cap
du million de décimales calculées.
Autant dire que dalle...
par rapport à l'infini
Et le 17 octobre 2011, après 371 jours,
non stop, de calculs par les ordinateurs,
on a passé le cap
des 10 milliards de décimales de π
Alors là on pourrait se dire qu'on s'approche
d'une valeur pas mal par rapport à notre 3,14...
non pas 15 !
C'était 18 à l'époque d'Archimède.
Mais pourtant encore une fois,
10 milliards par rapport à l'infini
c'est rien ! Aussi, on peut, comme ça,
continuer à rechercher ces décimales là.
Il y a donc des trucs amusants
à faire avec π ! Oui je te jure !
Pas que l'apprendre comme je l'ai fait dans la vidéo qui est juste ici avec notre pote As2Pik.
Alors comme on pressent que
c'est un nombre univers,
ça voudrait dire que, dans ses décimales,
on pourrait trouver
n'importe quelle séquence de chiffres définis.
Sur le site angio.net que vous retrouverez dans la description que je vais vous mettre,
vous pouvez chercher
si votre prénom est dans π.
Alors pour trouver votre prénom dans π,
il faut remplacer chaque lettre
par sa position dans l'alphabet.
Pour moi le F de Fabien c'est 6,
le A c'est 1,
le B c'est 2...
Et bien cette suite là,
elle existe dans π.
J'ai donc mon prénom
quelque part dans π.
J'aurais pu chercher
Fabien Olicard
et puis j'aurais pu chercher Fabien Olicard
suivi de ma date de naissance
Ou Fabien Olicard suivi de ma date de naissance
et de mon nombre d'abonnés aujourd'hui.
Il existe forcément un endroit dans π
où on trouvera ça.
Mais est-ce que cette séquence là existe entre 0 et 10 milliards ça je n'en suis pas encore certain...
Faudrait rechercher sur le site.
On peut également s'amuser à faire
des représentations physiques π.
Alors il y a des magnifiques posters
qui existent,
où π est dessiné
avec ses propres décimales.
Je pense que un de ses jours je vais en mettre un là, quelque part, parce que je kiffe bien ça.
Je vous mets le lien également dans la description
Si vous regardez de très près,
ce sont toutes les décimales de π
qui sont marquées ;
toutes les décimales
qui tiennent dans le poster.
Il y a aussi des grands malades mentaux qui ont fait
une représentation de 4 millions de pixels
correspondants aux 4 premiers millions
de décimales de π.
Ça aussi c'est vrai,
je vous mets un lien dans la description,
ils ont juste décidé, de 0 à 9,
d'un code couleur
un code couleur pour un 0,
un code couleur pour 1, 2 etc...
Et ils en ont fait une représentation
comme ça, visuelle.
Alors là je vous parle du "Pi-day" du 14 mars,
mais il y a une date toute aussi importante.
En tout cas pour Michael Hartl.
Depuis 2010, il essaye de faire valider
le jour de "Tau", c'est le 28 juin.
Donc le 06/28
Et non pas le 3.14
C'est ce qu'on appelle le jumeau maléfique de π
Selon lui, on considère que π est faux.
Alors non pas dans sa définition,
ça elle est juste, mathématiquement parlant.
Mais parce qu'on considère plus souvent un cercle
par rapport à son rayon qu'à son diamètre.
Donc la constante est plus souvent définie par une circonférence divisée par un rayon, soit 2π et non pas π.
Ou alors   π  π
Mais je voulais absolument éviter
cette vanne dans cette vidéo.
Et c'est Bob Palais, un mathématicien qui, en 2001,
a donné l'appellation de "2π" -> "Tau"
Et voudrait lui aussi qu'on remplace
π par "Tau"
Et pour terminer avec une chose originale qu'on peut encore faire avec π en utilisant les décimales de π
Il y a quelqu'un qui a essayé de mettre en musique π
Ça c'est intéressant !
Il a pris donc les premières décimales 3,14159265358979323 etc, etc
pour en faire une représentation musicale.
Je vous mets un court extrait juste ici mais je vous mets surtout le lien de cette vidéo qui existe sur youtube
donc je ne vais pas lui prendre non plus sa vidéo, je vous invite si vous voulez la voir en entier à la regarder
[Extrait]
Je trouve ça très étonnant et,
encore une fois, très mélodieux.
Alors ça veut dire qu'on peut écouter π,
on peut voir π,
on peut faire aussi de l'anti-π
S'il y avait bien une journée pour vous parler de tout ça, c'était aujourd'hui, en ce jour du "Pi-day"
Pour terminer avec ce qui s'est passé
sur les vidéos de samedi et dimanche,
si vous les avez pas vu,
je vous recommande de regarder
peut-être, pour commencer,
la vidéo de dimanche.
Vous allez mieux comprendre.
Encore une fois,
ce n'était pas une vidéo agressive.
C'était un constat de ma part.
Un constat d'échec.
Je sais qu'il y en a beaucoup
qui ont dit :
"Oui mais par rapport au taux likes/dislikes, tu te focalises sur beaucoup de commentaires"
Alors ça c'est aussi un problème de communauté silencieuse dont je fais partie.
Je laisse souvent des likes,
par contre, je laisse
assez peu de commentaires ;
et bien ça laisse le champ libre
à des trucs comme il s'est passé samedi...
Je garde la décision, pour l'instant,
de ne pas refaire ce style là de vidéo.
Sauf si j'arrive à analyser où sont mes erreurs
et à le refaire en fonction.
Parce que même si, nous, les créateurs,
on fait des vidéos pour nous... Ok.
Çà, on est d'accord on fait ce qui nous plait
sur Youtube. Je suis le premier à prôner ça.
Mais, néanmoins, je fais partie de ceux
qui lisent vraiment tous les commentaires !
Et quand, 9 commentaires sur 10
disent la même chose
ou ont la même teneur en agressivité
ou disent le même truc
qui a été corrigé par un post épinglé...
Ben, en fait euh...
Non.
Tu n'as pas envie de le refaire.
Même si c'est quelque chose
qui te plait !
Mais j'avais quand même envie d'utiliser le droit de réponse qu'est ma propre chaine, évidemment.
Puisque répondre dans
les commentaires, moi-même,
ça ne suffisait pas, puisque le com
en question n'était pas lu.
Vous pouvez par contre liker cette vidéo, que vous fassiez partie de la communauté active ou silencieuse
Vous pouvez aussi me laisser un commentaire pour me dire ce que vous avez pensé de tout ça
Et là, encore une fois, je m'adresse encore une fois à la communauté active et la communauté pas silencieuse
#PasSilencieuse
Ça va être le nouvel hashtag de cette chaine,
je veux le voir partout !
Vous pouvez le mettre partout
où vous voulez sur le Net
#Ne soyez plus silencieux.
Pas silencieux les mecs !
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner
et rendez-vous très bientôt.
Je pense que ça va être samedi matin à 11h, Ciao !
[Musique générique de fin]